you've got to be willing to suffer to
reach BIW best in world it is very hard
to come up with your Sistine Chapel got
it it is even harder to become a
Michelangelo the hours that ordinary
people waste extraordinary people do at
the end of the day we are a bunch of
people on a little planet in a huge
galaxy and before you know we're going
to be a bunch of dust you cannot get to
the mountaintop without taking a few
missteps he's a Canadian writer speaker
leadership expert and former litigation
lawyer he's the author of 15 global
bestsellers including the monk who sold
his Ferrari he's the founder of a
Business Leadership Training firm Sharma
leadership international he's Robin
Sharma and here's my take on his top ten
rules for success number one is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
her on although to the end for some
special bonus clips I mean the reality
is reading a book or going to a
conference or having a great
conversation where you get this golden
information that's all fantastic but
what makes mastery is execution on the
ideas not the ideas and so no idea works
unless you're willing to roll up your
sleeves do the practice invest the time
put in the effort do the work I think
we've all observed a lot of people who
they love reading the books they love
showing up at the courses they do all
the online training and nothing ever
changes and they say well you know I
don't know why it doesn't change why my
life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger to practice one thing that
makes them great is they are willing to
sacrifice I mean yes they're passionate
but did you know the root of the word
passion is suffering you've got to be
willing to suffer for your vision you've
got to be willing to suffer to reach BIW
best in world you've got to be willing
to suffer the ridicule and laughter of
your critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class nothing fails
like success you're successful maybe
it's in your health maybe it's in your
finances maybe it's in your career maybe
it's in your family life maybe it's in
the way that you show up in the world
awesome
you're in a really vulnerable place
right now it is one thing to be
successful it is another thing to
sustain success over the coming decades
is that it not a powerful idea I mean
let's go to the entertainment industry
it's very hard to be a one-hit wonder
let's not knock a one-hit wonder but
it's even harder to become an iconic
rock band or hip hop band let's go to
the Arts it is very hard to come up with
your Sistine Chapel got it it is even
harder to become a Michelangelo so are
you playing the short game are you
playing the long game this is rule
number two you know or lesson number two
the life has taught me play the long
game aim for legendary don't just say I
want to be world-class in my dominant
pursuit for a little window of time say
I want to have the guts and the grit and
the occupant and the mindset and the
capability and the commitment to create
enduring success and that's why I say
nothing fails like success you look at
the restaurant that is hot in your
neighborhood right now they're on the
path to obsolescence if they're not
really careful
sure they went from a little
neighborhood shop that made beautiful
pasta that had great service that had
the owner on the floor shaking your hand
getting to know your name then they got
written up in the magazines and they
then they got interviewed and then word
of mouth spread like wildfire and what
happened they became arrogant
you see success can be so toxic and it
happens it is such a pull on every human
being it just plays with your mind and
you literally shift
from humility to arrogance you shift
from humility to arrogance and once the
arrogance sets in in a mindset it starts
to populate every other person on the
team every other person in the culture
every other person in the community and
it is a very short fall from success to
irrelevance so lesson number two is
nothing fails like success as you become
more successful become more humble as
you become more successful work even
harder as you become more successful
care even more about your product as you
become more successful learn even more
I invite you it when you are the the
Titan of your industry be sitting in the
room with 18 year olds beginning their
game when you are the the icon of your
field be the person who is up not a five
o'clock anymore let's play at four
o'clock reading listening to the podcast
writing in your journal setting your
goals focusing on your intentions as you
become more successful be more humble as
you become more successful be even more
punctual as you become more successful
become even more passionate as you
become older become even younger
yesterday I was walking on the street
and I met this man in his 80s he said
Rob and I finally retired he's probably
close to 90 and he is a legendary
clothier in the country that I live in
and he just retired and he started his
shop which is now an empire in 1954 so I
don't know what that is but that is
decades and decades and decades and
decades and he did not want to retire he
just retired but he is still on fire to
do amazing things
age is just a number do not let an old
person into your body nothing fails like
success number 3 unbelievably important
which is the importance of scheduling
you know I talk a lot a lot about having
a dream having a plan you know being
inspired but all ideas don't work unless
you do the work
some of the best work you can do is
getting really good at creating a
one-page plan have your big five the
five things that need to happen this
year for this to be your best year yet
on a one-page plan your top five values
put them on that same plan your top five
sub goals sequenced into each quarter of
this year on that one page plan and
every morning all your competition or
the rest of the world is asleep get up
at 5:00 a.m. I'll teach you how to do
that in future videos but look at your
one page plan to spend twenty minutes on
that so it becomes a brain tattoo a
burning obsession so it alights you with
inspiration so you blow up the world and
you understand that clarity is power and
you so intimately know what has to
happen during this day this week this
month this quarter this year to get you
closer to your mountain top because the
ordinary through the hours that ordinary
people waste extraordinary people do
because they're not bored like most
people most people need to medicate
themselves with too much TV
too much Facebook too much video too
much chitchat
too much busyness because they don't
know their goals because they don't have
a one-page plan because they don't have
a one-page schedule I mean I've got my
schedule for every seven days almost
everything I need to do goes on it and
you might say Robin well that's a very
rigid way to live no it's a very free
way to live because then I have the
power to live life on my own terms I
feel inspired I'm not wasting each day
I'm leveraging each day the fourth point
become outrageously enthusiastic and
again you're gonna say Robin let's hold
hands and sing Kumbaya you know being
enthusiastic isn't important next thing
you're going to tell me is get up in the
morning look in the mirror and saying I
think I am I think I am am I like myself
I like myself I like myself I like
myself but isn't it true that the most
enthusiastic person in the room
influences people and they elevate
people and they encourage people another
issue of fortune magazine a little while
ago did a did a story on Richard
Branson's Necker Island
conference invited all sorts of amazing
people and the reporter in the room said
something I've never forgotten the
reporter said it was striking to me how
in each of the conference sessions the
moguls of these giant firms were always
the most enthusiastic people in the
rooms
it's amazing to me when I meet
world-class CEOs they are the most
humble the most passionate they're the
most engaged they're the most lively
people in the room I think it's
fundamentally important to be the most
enthusiastic person you know I think in
so many ways leadership is about
inspiring people by your example it goes
back to to my dad you know and he was
very much about humility I mean he's 77
right now and he he gets up every
morning and he goes off to his medical
practice and he still sees patients all
day and he said in I said dad why are
you still doing that at 77 he said
because my patients need me and so I
think you know one of the core values he
was so brilliant and sharing with me is
to be an instrument of service and I
think the moment your ego runs your
brain and the ego runs your business and
the ego runs your way of being then your
your gifts and your talents and your
focus and your capabilities are off the
creativity and the talents and the
service that will make you great in the
world and I think it gets to a very
philosophical point if I may
yeah I think it's relevant to any leader
any entrepreneur any business builder
any game changer but you know I mean
that there is such an addiction to the
shiny toys that the ego sells us okay
and in society and the matrix and our
peers and the world says if you get a
Ferrari if you get if you sell ten
million books if you have lots of money
in the bank if you have you know the
beautiful partner in the big house then
you're going to wake up every morning
and look in the mirror and you are going
to feel full of joy and peace and feel
you're fully alive and you know I've had
most of those in my life
at a pretty exponential level I've been
very blessed and not one of those things
has provided me with enduring
sustainable happiness and fulfillment
and the things that provide me with just
deep happiness and deep fulfillment and
energize me all come from a position of
inner power and so you know what the
events you're talking about I don't
drive much power from all the books I've
sold or bestseller I don't care about
that stuff
I really don't I care less about that
than ever before at the end of the day
we are a bunch of people on a little
planet in a huge galaxy and before you
know we're going to be a bunch of dust
and the great billionaire's get buried
next to the taxi drivers and the pizza
makers and we are not that big a deal
and I think all that really matters is
while we are alive you know do your best
to use every day as a vehicle to birth
your talents into the world and secondly
if you do that you're going to serve the
world and raise the world with you and
and that all just comes from inner power
I mean that's just driving your power
from the place within you know that's
where you get grace and that's where you
get great creativity that's where you
get boundless energy because it's not
about addicted to what the world thinks
of you yeah I think failure is the
highway to success and I know that
sounds like a platitude but Society or
people teach us right they say oh if you
fail and feel uncomfortable you've done
something wrong and what I try to do in
all of my books and my presentations and
my tweets and is them you cannot get to
the mountaintop without taking a few
missteps and so a business that wants to
win you have to out fail your
competition and as human beings you know
failure is not a bad thing you know ask
yourself what's the opportunity from the
failure and get in the game because when
you get to the last hour of your last
day it will not be the failures you
regret it'll be all the risks you didn't
take we become our standards in many
ways if you are surrounded by B players
or average performers the and that is
your standard then your mindset will
operate at the standard
that is that is offered to you by the
people around you I mean we do become
our social orbit and if you are at a
standard internally that I want to be a
game changer in my field I want to be
BIW the best there ever was I want to be
the van Gogh and the Rembrandt of
Technology or whatever field you play in
then your behavior always matches your
internal identity and your inner
standards so your standards are
important your standards for your
friendships your standards for the
quality of the work you do the standards
of your languaging the standards of the
nutrition you put into your body the
standards of your love life the
standards of your mindset the standards
of the way you occur in the world and so
my invitation for you regardless of what
you do is that you raise your game to a
place called world class and that is all
about being a game changer now I should
caution you and I don't like that word
because language is so powerful and
caution is a word that really is a
little dramatic but I want to caution
you which is as you leave the herd and
the crowd and perhaps the cult of
mediocrity and rise to being a game
changer it's a very disruptive act and
you actually threaten the masses of
people around you and that's why every
visionary was first ridiculed before
they were revered and I'm sure you've
experienced it you want to set you say
you know I want to take my fitness to a
whole new level of world class or I want
to take my craft to a whole new level of
world class or maybe you're raising your
game financially and then you share with
those you love or your friend your
friends and maybe your friends are those
you love and they laugh at you and how
many times have we given up on a dream
because we were mocked by the people
around you and all I'm suggesting to you
is when you get laughed at and ridiculed
and when people don't understand your
next level of world class that just
means you've got a great dream and that
just means you're on the path of growth
so be a game changer I run what I call
the twenty Twenty twenty formula I
shared it with it and and you know many
people around the world have found great
value from it it's pretty simple I mean
it sort of rolls about
- what the Spartan warriors once said
and they said that the person who sweats
more in training bleeds lessen war and
whether you're an entrepreneur whether
you're an artist whether you're a baker
whether your yoga teacher whether you're
a mom whether you're a street sweeper
you know you when you walk out in the
world there's a call on your life to
bring your best game to the world and
release as much talent as possible and a
lot of people what they do is they get
up every morning and they sort of run
their day by default and they're chasing
the day and they let life act on them in
a very reactive way and so I think what
we want to do is see ourselves as as
warriors of some sort where we take from
five to six every morning and we prepare
ourselves mentally physically
emotionally and spiritually and so to
give a tactic to your to your many
listeners it's the 20-20-20 formula
first twenty minutes as soon as you get
up five to five twenty intense exercise
and that's going to do a whole bunch of
things you know a lot of my work is very
science-based and it's going to create a
pharmacy of mastery so you're going to
release dopamine which is the
motivational neurotransmitter you're
going to reduce cortisol in your brain
which is the fear chemical you're going
to release serotonin which even if
you're cranky you start to feel good
you're going to release BDNF which
scientists are calling Miracle Grow for
the brain which I actually allows your
brain cells to repair from stress I mean
this is exciting to me yeah that's right
so that first 20 minutes you rewire your
brain what else do you do you jumpstart
your metabolic rate what else do you do
you prepare yourself for resilience
against stress and it just goes on and
on second part of the 20-20-20 formula
you plan you pull out a journal you can
do it an imprint of your day which is
very powerful or you can look at your
big five or your plan that releases hope
it releases focus right because an
addiction to distraction is the death of
creative production Tony okay and then
the final part of the 2020 formula
learning I mean he or she who learns the
most wins what made Steve Jobs Steve
Jobs or an Elon Musk is they know more
than anyone around them and so I believe
that
you know the more you know the more you
can achieve and there's great value
investing as much money as you have into
audiobooks or programs like you do at
the genius you know the 25k conference
and the genius network or whatever it is
but you know every quarter I make sure I
get out of my office and I go off to a
conference I invest a lot of money in
learning and training and coaching and
that's the 20-20-20 formula small wins
matter I mean we sometimes think that an
epic life occurs one Sunday sunny Friday
afternoon when the stars line up and
something revolutionary occurs and what
I'm suggesting to you with great love
and great respect is a great life is
built not by revolution a great life is
built by evolution small and steady wins
the race what you do every day is far
more important than once you what you do
once every decade I want to really think
about that idea what you do every day is
simply your life in miniature and as you
live every single day so you're crafting
your life what you do over the next hour
is is really building your future and if
you can just get and I can just get
every single pocket of 24 hours right as
best as we humanly can the rest of our
life is going to take care of itself
so small wins matter you know the moment
in front of the customer where the pull
was to go average and you become merch
enough Wow set you up for the next day
of a way of being of WoW the little win
with your family when you feel like
watching TV set you up for another win
the next day a little win of getting up
at 5 o'clock and running your morning
routine sets you up for a habit of a 5
a.m. Club morning routine small daily
improvements over time will lead you to
stunning results tiny wins are the way
to greatness and that's one of the
things life has taught me when you look
at the great companies whether it's an
Amazon whether it's you know some of
some of the tech startups coming out
right now whether it's a Zappos whether
it's a
whether it's a Nike whether it's a
General Electric whether it's some of
the you know the little shops in your
neighborhood that we really admire
because people still cook the food with
love or they serve the food with love or
people have an attention to detail great
companies are built by those small
steady optimizations every single day if
you look at any great product it wasn't
just one day that built the great
product it was a culture and a mindset
of daily innovation and optimization
when done consistently over time which
led to world-class even-even
relationships a great relationship it's
all about those small daily wins when
done consistently leads to a lifetime of
love I was walking in the woods last
week and there were these there was an
elderly couple walking in front of me
and they really stood out because they
were moving fast and I and they were
also like they had these ski poles and
so this I mean this is the autumn in my
hometown and they were walking with
these ski poles and so I started joked
as I walked by them because pretty much
only the three of us in this deep forest
and I said you're missing the cell and
they sort of laughed and we actually
walked for about half an hour and we
started going pretty deep and they said
to me you know we've been married 52
years and I said fifty-two years what's
your secret and the woman says well
we've I've had to put up with a lot
which made me laugh and then it was all
about a little small daily things they
did to foster a lifetime of love I was
in Johannesburg a little while ago and I
went through the the airport and I went
into the men's room or washer room or
bathroom however you want to call it and
so I walked in debt to the men's room
and the first thing I hear is welcome to
my office
and this was the janitor at the
Johannesburg men's room that's funny
hoo-hoo janitor eyes door I'll make up a
word cleaned the men's the toilets like
Mozart composed music
now that man has no money that man
probably has very little education that
man is judged by the world as having an
unimportant job right and that man is a
hero could be here two millions of
people why because he actually saw
himself as an ambassador to South Africa
and his passion was was palpable and his
visceral commitment to doing work at the
highest level was like you don't see
even from the CEOs and all I'm saying is
even the person in the with the broken
heart the person who's down on their
knees whether they see it or not they
have a choice to rise above their
circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it I mean you read read
the group you look at Mandela you know
27 years in imprisonment when his son
died he wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son he said that was
the one of the great pains of his own of
his life and what did he do the victim
looks at something like that torture and
says I am broken and they give up and
they spend that they closed their heart
they closed their mind they closed their
creativity and they blame the rest of
their life on what happened to them but
Mandela what he chose to do was to use
it as an opportunity because actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart and adver
fear the world says fear is bad fear is
only an opportunity for bravery training
and what he did was he used those 27
years of torture to open his himself
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually to the point where when he
was released and became the president of
South Africa he invited his jailers to
sit in the front row at his inauguration
and he was asked why and he said because
if I don't I'm still good I'd still be
in prison and that's a long way of
saying but you know we do make excuses
because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
I making sense or tulino you talk
you don't have to leave what's safe I
mean we are addicted to crisis sometimes
it makes no sense we are addicted to
pain and we'd have to actually leave the
pain to go out to the possibility of
pleasure and joy and greatness and
believe it or not that frightens us
right so we make these excuses and then
we blame people Oh Joe or Robin I don't
like the way he looks I he speaks
differently but subconsciously as you're
suggesting those are just our protective
mechanisms to avoid owning the
responsibility of our brilliance
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Jamal M asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur you
want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of the
top 10 rules have the biggest impact on
you and why what change is going to make
in your business as a result of watching
this video leave in the comments and I
will join in the discussion finally I
want to give a quick shout out to
Christoph logee's thank you so much for
buying my book and means a lot to me for
those of you bought make sure you email
in your receipt the information and the
link is in the description below thank
you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
van Gogh I heard this recently van Gogh
never made a penny from his paintings
until he died
he did it for the love of his work I do
it for the love of my work I know you do
it for the love and work bono does it
for the love of his work Warren Buffett
did it for the love does it for the love
of his work Steve Jobs was a billionaire
and he worked harder than ever before
because he it was a dream in the love of
the love of his work and doing something
awesome for the world people like Mozart
and Beckham and and the great athletes
humanitarians entrepreneurs chess
champions were less about genetics and
gene and natural talent and what makes
icons in whatever field of you choose is
not your talent it's things like the
amount that you practice your ability to
stay with your practice for the 10,000
hours your social circle I mean what
made the great Brazilian footballers
great was not that they have some
natural thing by living in Brazil it's
every little kid from pretty much the
moment he's three or four years older
right
sees the heroes and it's the ticket out
of poverty and so all they do is touch
the football every single day and night
and by the time they're 11 years old
they've touched the football millions of
times and they're therefore untouchable
compared to anyone else around the world
and all I'm saying is genius is not
something you're born with this genius
is something that you apply you don't
you don't get lucky you make lucky
success is not something that is you
know divinely bestowed on you success
whether it's prosperity or whatever it
is is something that you earn by grit
hard work finding the right people doing
the learning etc today's a miracle
you'll never get this day again in your
life part of success is building a great
career building a great financial life
building great fitness but also
understanding that the greatest joys in
life are life's simplest blessings make
the time to watch the Sun come up make
the time to listen to a great piece of
music today make the time to have a
conversation with a stranger and restore
their sense
humanity make the time to look for a
great piece of art somewhere make the
time to read from a book on business or
creativity or productivity or time
management because the world belongs to
the learners make the time to tell your
kid how much you love them
make the time to write a thank-you note
to that mentor who shaped you make the
time today to look up the stars because
if they only came out once every 100 of
years you'd be wowed by them make the
time to express some gratitude if you
have two eyes two feet a roof over your
head people who care about you you are a
very blessed person